Prague in a lot of trouble
Knight F3 the knights are running amok
White's counter play on The Queen side
has not amounted to anything and Carlson
has left himself with three whole
minutes on the clock to figure out the
last couple of touches here black is
completely winning here but Prague will
continue to fight until the last drop of
blood he tries to get the Rooks off the
board but Carlson can play Rook A3 and
there's got to be some sort of a
checkmating mechanism here Knight H3 and
Rook A3 wins the game it wins a piece
exactly
and Magnus pauses because he knows
exactly that yes this is it
let me just be precise
and die yes on the board Knight ga5 to
HD check no matter where white is going
King F1 or King H1 will have the same
problem that Lucas will follow with a
double attack on the bishop Andrew K1
Checkmate the knights just Monster
Knights
and it took Carlson so much time and so
much finesse to get those nights to
where they are it took a lot of
turnarounds and the initiative changed
hands but Carlson laughs last and he
will last laugh longest in this first
game he will just move his King to F6
getting away from the checks and the
threat of Rook A1 Checkmate and Rook
takes a four forces prognananda to
resign the first game and you can see
there a dejected Prague will not have a
lot of time to marinate on this game
because he has a task in front of him
and that is to win the next game with
the black pieces Peter
yeah it's a Mamu Tusk we have to give
credit for Magnus sensationally sensing
the moment and that King Marsh with King
f8 King E7 prepared his uh activation of
his rook and once The Rook activated
itself then the knights were jumping for
the big victory from Magnus Carson